si dans mon gars d'une arme de
dissuasion massive des branches et les
russes du réseau inter-bancaire swift
bonjour gauthier rybinski dont julien
quoi s'agit-il alors swift d'abord c'est
une coopérative de droit belge qui avait
été créée dans les années 1970 à quoi
sert-elle ce sont en fait des messagerie
sécurisée pour procéder très rapidement
à des transactions précisément encore de
manière sécurisée si on retire on
débranche comme vous disiez les banques
russes au nombre de 300 à peu près de ce
système de cette messagerie ça veut dire
qu'il faudra procéder comme à l'ancienne
avec le feu fax même si ça fait
longtemps que le fax da plus de
manivelle pour être activé là réside
d'être un peu long mais ça risque d'être
très long et justement quand il s'agit
de très gros montants par exemple la
facture de gaz que que la russie en
caisse c'est quelque chose d'intéressant
en terme de sanction je remarque autre
chose c'est que cette sanction donc le
déconnexion de la russie où des banques
russes de ce système de cet organisme
swift vient dans le cas et ça les
ministres de l'europe sont très claires
dans le cas où la russie poursuivrait
son avant ça veut dire que d'emblée on a
entériné la perte pour l'ukraine des
régions actuelles du donbass qui sont
donc occupés à la fois par les
séparatistes et 13 mai devant par une
assistance militaire russe conséquente
voyez déjà ce que ça veut dire c'est à
dire que on était dans un autre cadre
qui veut dire on attend on aborderait
cette mesure on envisagerait cette
mesure si les russes avancé
jusqu'où je sais pas qu'est ce qui reste
après swift jusqu'à kiev vous voyez donc
on retarde en quelque sorte on prend un
sursis par rapport à ce qui peut être
beaucoup plus grave en disant attention
on va se fâcher c'est ça me rappelle la
manière dont françois mitterrand avait
traité avec slobodan milosevic à
l'époque de la gare ans en croatie et en
serbie où régulièrement il avertissait
le dictateur serbe que les choses
allaient se gâter et de fait le
dictateur serbe n'a jamais tenu compte
de ces avis et de ses admonestations en
tout cas ces sanctions vont peser dans
la vie quotidienne des russes est ce qu
on sait ce que pensent les russes des
ambitions de la meilleure poutine alors
là aussi c'est compliqué en ce moment
parce que vous avez des instituts de
sondage certains sont encore libres dont
l'institut levada qui est totalement
indépendant du pouvoir mais qui est
extrêmement muselé et on serait pas
étonné que malheureusement dans un
avenir proche ils subissent ce que
d'autres associations organismes russes
ont subi c'est-à-dire d'être classé sous
l'étiquette agents de l'étranger qui est
infamante sur ton suspendu voilà alors
on est pas encore là heureusement mais
ça ça rend les choses difficiles pour
travailler parce que cet institut était
particulièrement intéressant deux choses
sur la question que vous me posez il y a
d'un côté la reconnaissance des russes à
vladimir poutine pour le fait qu'il est
sorti de la misère un certain nombre de
russes et un nombre conséquent donc on
lui doit une reconnaissance mais vous
avez très curieusement parmi les gens
qui jusqu'à présent s'estimer satisfait
de vladimir poutine des personnes qui
n'ont jamais profité de démesure de
poutine qui a favorisé comme on le dit
une classe moyenne ça veut dire que au
delà de la question matérielle de la
précarité existentielle habituel il y à
la question de l'idéologie et parfois
des gens qui sont fascinés par vladimir
poutine même si eux-mêmes
personnellement sont toujours au bord de
la misère donc ça veut dire que si les
sondages permettent de dire que les
russes moyennement en faveur de poutine
parce qu'on l'a dit l'ukraine est un
petit frère il qu'on voit pas pourquoi
on va attaquer le petit frère on ne
saura pas forcément pour pourquoi parce
que comme le dicton le dit quand on
quand il fait froid on casse le
thermomètre c'est en train de faire le
pouvoir russe merci beaucoup gauthier